GREG: Chris is going to
give us a demo of managed
virtual machines.
He's going to take an
application like Brad used,
but he's going to add in, now,
C++ code and some open source
packages, while still keeping
the capabilities that he
thought App Engine was
great for to begin with.
So Chris why don't you show
us managed virtual machines.
CHRIS: Cool, thanks, Greg.
Appreciate it.
So what I want to
show you today is
how we use managed VMs to
take and add real time image
collaboration in the cloud
and add that to Brad's demo.
Alright?
So what we're going
to do is we're
going to have clients that
are running inside of Chrome,
they're communicating
back with a fleet
of managed VMs via WebSockets,
for low latency communications.
Right?
And on those managed
VMs we're going
to rely on ImageMagick, a third
party, open source library,
that's an optimized C library,
for doing image processing
and image rendering.
They want to use local disk
to cache the renderings,
make it super snappy.
They want to use App Engine's
Java runtime as a serving stack
to get data flowing from the
front ends to the back ends.
Now, as Greg alluded to,
that kind of technology
is not typically supported
on platforms as a service.
And not what App
Engine is today.
With managed VMs, this
is totally possible.
Furthermore, we make
it very easy to get up
and started with this.
So let me show you.
I want to pop over
to my terminal here.
And what we see is a typical
App Engine configuration
file with a few parameters.
So we have an application,
we have a version,
we have what module's running.
With a few more lines
of configuration,
we're actually going to
turn this into a managed VM.
So let me walk through
these settings here.
So the first thing is,
we're setting VM true.
That's telling the system I want
to run this on a managed VM,
so I have access to native
resources and the ability
to run native code.
Furthermore, we get into a new
section called VM settings.
Here we specify machine
type, for example.
And since we're doing image
rendering and image processing,
we're going to crank up
the horsepower on these VMs
and deploy eight core machines.
GREG: Now this could be
any of the Compute Engine
virtual machine types.
One, two, four,
eight, or more cores.
High MEM, High CPU standard,
whatever is available in GCE,
you can use with
App Engine as well.
CHRIS: Absolutely, Greg.
And furthermore, as
we innovate here,
those innovations will flow back
to this configuration as well.
The next line is the settings
for deploying the third party
code that I want on those
managed VMs In this case
we're using ImageMagick and
just doing app-get install
to those managed VMs
GREG: And again,
anything installed
will be an apped get,
I can specify here,
and it becomes available
to me in a managed VM.
CHRIS: Absolutely, this
is how we're opening up
App Engine so you can use
third party libraries like that
and get them onto
those VMs, those
managed VMs, in a
super simple way.
The next line, is
we're opening up
a port, in this case it's
an arbitrary port 65080,
and that's how we're
going to do the WebSocket
communication from the
clients that are running
in Chrome, back to those
fleet of managed VMs.
And then for the
sake of this demo,
we're going to
specify two instances,
because that's more than
enough for this demo,
especially since we're
running eight core machines.
So we're going to escape
from this, save it.
Now since we're running
on the Java runtime,
and it's a Java application, we
can use Maven to deploy this.
OK, so while that's
running, I'm going
to talk about what's
happening under the hood.
So can we cut back to
the slides, please?
Alright, the first
thing that's happening
is that we're relying
on our G Cloud tools
to parse and to validate the
configuration file that I just
showed you.
Assuming that's
valid, which it is,
It's going to communicate
to our deployment endpoints
and say, OK, I want to
deploy this application.
Those deployment
endpoints are going
to store some metadata about
the application, the version,
the template, the number of
instances that are running.
And then from there
we're going to go off,
and we're going to create
the actual containers.
In this case, we're creating
eight core, Compute Engine VMs,
and we're installing our
Debian OS on top of that.
After that, we're going to
carve out the managed services
and make sure that everything's
lined up correctly for you.
So in this case, we're
going to do monitoring,
and health checking, task
queues, Memcache, and data
storing.
We're also going to
create secure name spaces,
so that everything
is secure within
those multi-tenant systems.
And we're going to
set up smart defaults,
so it's very easy
to access the APIs
and get data flowing
back and forth.
From there, it's on
to the serving stack.
And since we're running
on a Java runtime,
we're going to install a
web server, an application
server, and a JVM,
and then it's is
on to the interesting parts,
the parts that you provide.
So in this case,
the third party code
we specified, so ImageMagick
on those managed VMs.
And then, most
importantly, your code.
We're going to
bring all that up.
We're going to do
some health checking,
make sure everything's
running correctly.
I'm assuming it is.
We're going to install
a load balancer,
and then we're going to
wire everything up for you.
The final step is we're
going to take all of that
and make sure it's co-located
with the other pieces
of compute that your running.
So in this case,
Brad had showed you
some front ends
that were running.
We're going to take
your managed VMs
and co-locate those
with your front end,
so you get low latency and
improved overall performance.
Alright, so we can
jump back to the demo.
So our build has succeeded.
Let's go check
that out in Chrome.
So we'll pull this
up, and we'll navigate
to the URL that's
provisioned for us.
Alright, and there we
see our new front end,
cloud collabo,
collaboration in the cloud.
This is pretty straightforward.
We're going to be able
to upload an image.
We're going to do some
edits to that image.
Those edits are going to
be shared with people that
are collaborating, and we can
do some real time conversation,
back and forth.
So let's pick an image.
Alright, meme two looks good.
Alright, man of the
hour, Urs, we're
going to use his meme
to actually get going.
So that's uploading to
Cloud Storage right now.
Alright, there it is.
So it's uploaded, we see that
I'm the only collaborator.
So let's change that.
I'm going to share
this with Greg.
Now demo [? note, ?] I'm
going to use Chrome profiles
to simulate Greg and myself
communicating back and forth.
So we're going to bump
over to Greg's profile.
Oh yes, looks just
like you, Greg.
Oh, you're a "Despicale
Me" fan as well.
I love it.
It's great.
That is like the craziest theme
I've ever seen in my life.
Alright, back to business.
OK, so I'm sharing this
with Greg right now.
It's going out, it's
going to log him in.
Wait for it.
There he is, alright.
And you see now
that Greg and I are
collaborating on this image.
Now to show you
happening in real time,
as I try to move
this over here--
So I'm going to pretend
that Greg is actually
doing the editing,
and you're going
to see things happening, if
everything works correctly
in my browser as well.
So we'll dress it up
with a frame first.
Nothing goes with
green like magenta.
Grab that.
Add border.
Alright, good,
we've got a border.
And now we're going to add
some high end doodling.
Somebody had mentioned that
doodling on Urs's image
is probably a
career ending move.
I said hey, why not.
GREG: Only if the
demo doesn't work.
[LAUGHING]
CHRIS: Exactly.
So we're going to give Urs a
big smile, good prices in cloud,
and his famous earring,
a little more bling.
There we go.
And now we see that it's
happening in real time
back to my browser.
And so, again
what's happening is
that these two clients,
connecting over
WebSockets back to managed VMs.
We're doing the rendering,
we're caching in local disks,
then we're sending updates
back to the Chrome clients.
Now I want to take a second
and say, to all the App Engine
developers and users
that are in the crowd,
this typically wasn't and was
not supported on App Engine.
But yet it's been a top feature
request, consistently, year
over year.
So I'm happy to announce that
those feature requests are now
fixed, and available to you.
OK, so it's not just about--
thank you, thank you,
thank you, all the App Engine
developers in the crowd.
So while the ability to
access native resources
and run native code on these
managed VMs is fantastic,
it's not just about that.
It's about great developer
experiences and great developer
integration.
So to show you that,
I'm going to bump
back out to the
developers console here.
It's the same UI that
Brad had shown previously,
it's our developers console.
And I'm going to show how
we've integrated App Engine
and Compute Engine by drilling
down into the App Engine tab.
And we see our dashboard.
We see our modules.
I'm going to select our
back end module, that's
the one that's handling
all the real time
collaboration and communication.
We'll drill into the instances.
And here we'll see
the instances that
are running from my application.
So, remember, back in
the configuration file,
we specified that we
want two managed VMs.
Here we see those.
And if we drill into
this VM over here,
give it a second, OK.
And so there's the dashboard
for the underlying VM.
And if we move
down the page, you
can see that it is, in
fact, an eight core machine.
We've automatically configured
an external IP for it.
And there's some
metadata here that
allows us to manage the VM,
quite a bit of it actually.
So that's drilling
down into the VM.
Now we'll have to
bubble back up and see
how we've integrated all
the managed services.
We come back to
the App Engine tab,
we'll go to our
unified logs viewer.
Now what's nice about this,
is it's not just unifying
the logs on all my managed VMs.
It's actually unifying the
logs across all the compute
that I'm doing.
Be it a front end
running on App Engine,
or managed VMs that are running
on top of Compute Engine VMs.
So here we see that there
is a fair number of servlets
that are being hit,
for my back end.
Got one for serving
up an image, one for
create a WebSockets connection.
And while you could do all
of this on an unmanaged VM,
you could do it on a
raw Compute Engine VM,
you could deploy
syslog or rsyslog.
We think there's
more productive way.
We think that by offering a
managed and centralized service
like this, you become a
more productive developer.
And furthermore, if you
apply that philosophy out
to things like authentication,
deployment management,
configuration management,
developer tools,
developer console,
that you could
be a more productive and
happier developer for the cloud.
Now let's take a look at
how-- speaking of developer
productivity, let's
take a look at what
we do with the underlying VMs.
Now, we had mentioned that these
VMs are locked down by default.
So they're not-- you
don't have root access,
you don't have SSH
access in to them.
And that's for a good
reason, we don't want people
going out into production
and making changes
to one of those VMs
that are running inside
of a large fleet.
It makes it hard to manage
within a high availability
manner.
But we recognize
the fact that there
are times when you need
to get to those VMs
to do things like-- do
some kind of debugging,
or check on a configuration
file that you have,
or make some
configuration change,
just to see what happens
to the underlying VM.
We make that super
simple as well.
So if we come back
here to the terminal,
we're going to do a G Cloud--
instances-- [INAUDIBLE] gcloud
compute-- instances--
list-- and there's
our two VMs that are
actually running.
And now we're going to enable
debugging for one of those.
So I'm going to do gcloud
debug-- [INAUDIBLE]
compute debug.
Use the local
directory, which has
the configuration for
these managed VMs.
And what that's
going to do is it's
going to go through that
deployment end point
and put those two managed
VMs into debug mode, which
is what you're seeing here.
I'll clear that up.
And if we do gcloud compute
instances-- list, again.
So I can grab the name.
Let's grab the first one,
and we'll SSH into that.
So we'll grab that guy.
Instead of list, we'll do SSH.
OK.
Now that'll SSH us
into the underlying VM,
what you see here,
cramsdil@ae-backend1-0.
Clear that up.
once we're on this VM, you
have access to common tools
you would normally use
on a virtual machine.
In this case we do
things like run netstat.
We see all the
activity that's running
through the various
connections on the VM.
In this case, we can actually
see up there at 65080
with the port we're listening
on for the WebSockets
communication.
And then we can do
things like interact
with the Debian
package [INAUDIBLE]
and see that the package that we
specified inside configuration
file is actually on the VM.
In this case we would
do DDKG and we'll
do a grep for the same Magick.
And sure enough, there you
see that, in the bottom
there, we see that our
package is actually
installed on the VM.
And so all we need
to do is we exit,
we'll seal that VM back up,
and things are good to go.
So what we've seen here
is that with managed VMs,
we can take advantage
of the auto management
the App Engine provides with
the control and flexibility
of underlying
Compute Engine VMs.
We make it super
simple to get started
with easy configuration,
easy deployments,
integration back with
managed services,
as well as integration
with our developer
console and our developer tools.
So that you don't have
to make a choice between
I want platform as a
service and auto management,
or I want to choose flexibility
with Compute Engine.
Managed VMs brings
both of those together,
giving you the best
of both worlds.
And so, with that, I'm going
to turn it back over the Greg.
GREG: Thanks, Chris.
[APPLAUSE]